[Music]
Frank Sheeran SNL right yeah you said
under the contract management can only
fire driver on very specific charges so
you have a show of place give any moving
violations no do you drink on the job
no never hit anybody on a job yeah I
don't think so alright then we don't
have nothing to worry about
want you to be my cousin Russell
Bufalino oh yeah hey nice to meet you
who's like the army
you're followed orders you did the right
thing
you got rewarded
a friend of ours is having new trouble
friend that the cop back then there was
nobody in this country who didn't know
who Jimmy Hoffa was always charge a guy
with a gun with a knife you run away so
you're charged with a gun with a knife
you run hiya Frank would you like to be
a part of history
yes I would big business and the
government working together trying to
pull us apart
something's got to be done what else you
say now's not the time to not say we're
going at war with EP war things you've
got a nanny with our friends you gotta
sit down everybody says so it's what it
is where this I knew things they jump in
the wine
it's gonna happen either way he's going
[Music]
you know I don't okay well you did it or
not that makes no difference to me yeah
I'm here to defend you
right right do you wanna know if I did
[Music]
[Music]